We continue our analysis of the US Iran
war. And in this war, there are three
major questions
that will determine the outcome of this
war as well as the world afterwards.
Okay. And these three questions are
number one,
will the US launch a ground invasion?
So right now the United States and
Israel are primarily focused on a air
war striking
um Iran from a distance. In the past we
would call this siege warfare.
And as long as it remains an ear war,
the United States can choose to
deescalate and withdraw from the Middle
East. They would lose this war, but the
loss would not be catastrophic.
Whereas if they choose to launch a
ground invasion,
it would escalate very quickly and they
would be trapped in Iran for the next 5
to 10 years. It would be a catastrophe
whether or not they win or lose because
in order to fight a ground war, United
States would have to institute a
national draft where a young man um as
young as 18 would be forced to join the
army and be sent to fight in Iran. Okay,
so that's the first big question for us.
Will the United States send in ground
troops? Remember this. There's the idea
of mission creep where maybe in the
beginning you're like, I'll send out
a,000
troops to do a small mission, but then
it doesn't go well. So you send in
2,000. Okay, it slowly creeps up. It's
what we call mission creep. That's how
the United States embroiled itself in
Vietnam. All right, so that's the first
big question. Second big question is,
will nukes be used?
There's a lot of concern
online that Israel is preparing a
nuclear strike on Iran because the
Israelis don't like how the world how
how the war is going and they want to
reclaim the initiative.
Nukes are a taboo in geopolitics.
The Americans used them at the end of
World War II and no one's used them ever
since.
If Israel were to use tactical nuclear
weapons, they would break this universal
taboo and we might find ourselves in a
nuclear apocalypse. Okay, so that's a
great concern that everyone has right
now. And the third question is the Alax
mosque.
This is the third holiest site in the
Islamic world. There's Mecca, there's
Medina, and there's the Alax mosque. The
the Muslims believe that it is from the
alaxic mosque in Jerusalem where
Muhammad ascended to heaven
and the Jews believe that the Alexic
mosque sits on the site of their
temple which is the house of God. So
religious Jews, extremists want to
destroy the Alexic moss to rebuild the
third temple.
And if the religious Jews, the
extremists destroy the Azac mos, then
the two billion Muslims in this world
would be religiously obligated to go to
war against Ishel. Okay. So these are
the three big questions that um uh will
determine how this war will determine
the future of the world. Okay.
So um in this class I teach you game
theory to make predictions about the
future. So right now I'm going to make
three predictions.
um and then I'm I will show you my
analysis as to how I make these
predictions. Okay? Now, what's what's
important to understand is that these
are only my guesses based on my analysis
and whether or not they turn out correct
will determine the validity of my
analysis. I don't have inside
information. I don't know more than you
do. Okay? I'm just working out of public
knowledge and doing game theory
analysis. So according to game theory
this is yes. United States will send in
ground troops. According to game theory
this is no.
And number three is yes.
Okay. So what I'm going to do is my next
two classes explaining to you my game
theory analysis as to how I come to
these conclusions and we can watch how
world events unfold. Now I want you to
understand something which is that for
my theory to be valid for my analysis to
be valid. I have to be I have to be
correct on all three. Okay? If I miss
one then all my theory is wrong.
Um, I know there's a lot of concern from
around the world that nukes will be used
and I am 100% confident that nukes will
not be used at this time in this war.
And if I'm wrong, I apologize to the
world. Okay? But at the same time, we'll
all be dead anyway, so it doesn't really
matter. All right? Okay. All right. So
let me explain my analysis. Okay. So
remember today what I'm going to do is
do number one and number two. Explain to
you why Israel will not use new weapons
and why there will be a ground invasion.
And then next class I'll explain number
three to you. Okay. That's a plan for
this week.
All right. So to understand what's going
on, I need to I need to teach some basic
geopolitical theory. Okay. So in
military um affairs in geopolitics
there's a concept called escalation
ladder.
Escalation ladder.
Okay.
And the dominant theory is that whoever
has estrogen dominance
has the most advantage. Okay. So, so
what this means is let's just say you
and I get in a fight. Okay, I have a
knife. You have a gun. Well, gun is more
dominant than a knife. Therefore, you
have a greater advantage over me and
therefore you should win in theory.
Okay?
And apply to this war in the Middle
East. Israel and United States have
escalation dominance because they have
nuclear weapons and Iran doesn't.
Therefore, the United States and Israel
have a huge advantage over Iran. Okay?
But what I will show you today is that
this theory is incorrect. It actually
doesn't work that way. Right? So, let's
start off with very simple
um
example. Let's just say that two people
get into a fight, okay? A and B.
And how the escalation ladder will work
is that maybe A and B run into each
other. Okay? And then A says, "Hey man,
say sorry." And then B is like, "It's
not my fault. You say um sorry." Okay?
So there's a conflict and it's usually a
very small conflict. No one knows uh why
and no one knows who's at fault. Okay?
So they start cursing each other. Okay?
So the first step is a conflict. Second
step is they start cursing each other,
right? Screw you.
Screw you.
And then they might start pushing each
other, right?
Push. Push. And then they hit each
other. Okay. Punch. Punch. And then they
start the fight.
And then one pulls out a knife and the
other pulls out a gun. All right. and
then B should a fight over right okay so
there are certain things that we need to
keep in mind about this example first of
all the fight is not contained in itself
okay you cannot perceive this game as
just one between A and B who's
physically stronger there are other
players involved as well okay so for
example there are spe spe spe spe spe
spe spe spe spe spe spe spe spe spe spe
spe spe spe spe spe spectators or
friends,
there's a crowd watching you. Okay, this
is important because there's also the
police, right? Eventually the police
will come
um the government and they'll ask
people, "Hey, what happened, man? Whose
fault was it?" Right? And also for
people who are religious, there's also
God, right? If you die, you have to go
up to God heaven and God's going to ask
you, "Hey, man, how did you die?"
So you have to explain how you died. All
right? So in other words, in this
escalation ladder, there's three factors
that you have to consider that drive
people up this escalation ladder. These
three factors are of course emotions.
Second uh is power
and the third is reason or logic.
Okay? And what drives people up is
adrenaline.
In other words, it is impossible to go
to skip the escalation ladder, right?
You don't go from like, "Hey, screw
you." to like the guy pulling out a gun
and shooting you, okay? You have to go
step by step by step because adrenaline
is rushing in your system. And this
adrenaline, it's making you more angry,
but it's also making you stronger and
more resolved. And it's also telling you
how to fight this battle. Okay? And the
thing to remember about this is this is
really important is that it's not about
how fast you climb up the escalation
ladder. Okay? If you get too angry and
you overreact,
then you are at fault, right?
What you want to do is climb it up
strategically. And that means you have
to remain calm and controlled. Because
if you remain calm, controlled, you have
three advantages over your opponent. The
first is
um focus, second is clarity, and the
third is
um focus
uh you you're clear and resolve. Okay,
sorry. Resolve. Okay, what this means is
like you know what you're doing. You
have a strategy. You are clear about how
to achieve your strategy and your goal
and you are determined to achieve it.
Okay. But in order to have all three,
you have to remain calm. And therefore,
you need to control yourself as you
climb up this escalation ladder. Because
remember, it's just not about being your
opponent. It's about justifying yourself
to your friends, to the police, and to
God as well. Because you might hit that
person, he might go to hospital, and
you've won the fight, but then you go to
you go you go to prison for 10 years, in
which case you've lost the fight. Okay?
All right. So the main idea I want you
to remember is this and this is the law
of escalation
and this is a very important idea in my
game theory model.
Control
is more important than dominance.
Okay. Control is more important than
dominance. Why? Because control is the
idea of calibration.
Calibration means that you time or you
structure or you strategize your
response in a way that helps you achieve
your strategic objective. Okay? You're
not just throwing punches. You're
throwing a punch in a certain way that
allows you to defend yourself that
strikes fear in the opponent and also
allows you to seem as the good guy among
spectators.
Okay? And then when the police come, you
can justify why you threw a punch in a
certain way to the police so that you
don't go to jail. Okay? All right. So
another way of saying this is that
calibration is ultimately about
strategic flexibility.
And the idea of strategic flexibility is
in a fight, the person who has the most
options, the person who um
has the most flexible strategy will
usually win the fight. Okay. There's a
lot of escalation and I'll explain to
you how this applies to the US Iran war.
Okay. All right. So before I actually
talk about the war, what I what I want
to do is do is what I want to do is do a
thought experiment to examine how we can
understand what's going on between
United States and Iran. Okay. So let's
do a thought experiment. And thought
experiment is this. Let's just say that
there's a bully. Okay.
and he's the biggest guy in the school
and he has a gang. Okay, these are his
friends
and there's like uh maybe four of them.
And so what they do is
they basically pray on everyone at the
school. Okay? And there's maybe a
hundred people at the school, right?
And so what they do is they make
everyone in the cafeteria pay a tax.
Okay? If you want to go in the cafeteria
and eat, you have to pay a tax. Maybe a
dollar, who knows? Okay? And the friends
of the bully go collect the tax and then
give him all the money. Okay?
And that is the structure of the school
where if you want to eat lunch in the
cafeteria, you have to pay a tax and the
bully's friends collect the money and
the bully shares the money among amongst
his gang. Okay. Now, at first people are
okay with this system because they think
that it's actually beneficial because
the bully is keeping the peace and order
in that cafeteria, right? He's keeping
everyone safe. So yeah, I pay a dollar,
but it's not that much money and we're
all safe so that we can all enjoy our
lunch in peace in the cafeteria. Okay,
but then what happens over time is that
the bully
gets more and more arrogant because he
feels invincible. Everyone just obeys
him. So he develops the idea of hubris.
And the idea of hubris is that no one's
no one has the courage to challenge me.
Everyone's afraid of me and therefore I
can do what I want. So what does he do?
Well, the first thing he does is that he
charges more money from everyone. Okay?
So the tax goes up and so people are
disgruntled about this. Okay? They they
don't understand why they're paying more
to the bully. Okay? But not only that,
but what he will also do is pay less
money to his friends so that he can have
more money because he wants to buy a car
or he wants to go to Paris for the
summer. Okay, does that make sense?
Okay. So, everyone's not happy about
this, but but this the reality that they
live in and there's nothing they can do
about it and so people just put up with
it. One day a new kid comes into the
school. Okay, the new kid
and he doesn't really understand the
rules of the game. He goes to cafeteria
and he doesn't know he's supposed to pay
a tax, right? So the bully's friend
comes over and says, "Hey man, where's
where's the dollar?" And he's like,
"What dollar? I just got here." And he
refuses to pay. And so what they decide
to do is teach him a lesson by
ostracizing him, by making him sit alone
by himself in the cafeteria. Okay? You
have no friends because you don't know
the rules and you refuse to play along.
And the new kid is like, "I don't care.
I'm happy not having any friends." Okay?
And so then the bullying and his friends
start to discuss, "How can we get this
new kid to play along?"
And so they decide what they're going to
do is they're going to curse him.
They're going to bully him. Okay? So the
new kid goes to lunch and he's eating
his lunch and the friends come down and
start to curse him. Says, "You're a
wimp. Do you want to fight us?" And what
the new kid does is he just ignores
the these these guys. And these guys are
like, "What's going on, man? Why is he
afraid of us?" And slowly what happens
is that the other people, the other kids
recognize that, wow,
maybe it is possible to rebel against
the bully. Maybe it is possible not to
pay these stupid taxes.
And so they start talking to him
secretly. Okay? They give him presents.
They start say smile at him. They say hi
to him. Okay? But the new kid just
ignores everything, right?
And then the friends are like, "You know
what? We don't actually benefit this
much from this relationship anyway.
Maybe if we appoint this new kid as the
new bully, the new boss, he'll treat us
better." And then you have other friends
who are like, "You know what? This
bully, he's he's fat, he's ugly. Maybe I
should be the boss." Okay. So just
because a new kid comes in doesn't know
the rules and he's willing to challenge
the reality, challenge the assumptions,
the values of this cafeteria.
Now there's descent. Now there's
rebellion going on. Okay? And different
people are talking to him and
um trying to form alliances with him.
But what he does, and it's really really
interesting, is that he just ignores
everyone and keeps focused. Okay. And
then one day, um, the bully's friend
comes over and says, "You know what?
You're a whip." And the new kid finally
says, "I'm not afraid of you." Okay. And
then this friend goes back and tells his
boss, "Hey, this new kid said, "He's not
afraid of you, man. What are you going
to do about it?" The new and the bully
gets really angry. Says, "I'm going to
go punch his face." Okay. So, the bully
goes in front of Nuke and says, "If you
don't apologize,
I'm going to punch YOU IN THE FACE." And
the kid is like, "What did I do wrong?
What should I apologize for?" And the
bully's kind of confused. So, he goes
away, comes out next, AND SAYS, "YOU
APOLOGIZE NOW, MAN." AND THE kid's like,
"Okay, for what? Tell me tell me to
apologize for what?" And this goes on
for a long time, okay? And then
eventually the bully gets so pissed off
that he punches the new kid in the face.
Okay, so he started it. The new kid he's
he's he's um uh hurt, but he decides to
punch the bully back in the face. Okay,
and the bully stronger, so he beats the
bully up. So he beats up the new kid.
But what's happened now is that everyone
in the school has seen that the bully is
not that strong. everyone's seen that
the bully is actually um pretty weak and
so they recognize that hey if we stand
alongside the new kid we can beat the
bully.
All right and eventually what happens is
the bully is defeated. Does that make
sense to you guys? All right. So certain
things to understand is that yes,
the bully has escalation dominance
because he's stronger and he's the
biggest kid in the school. He he can
beat up everyone. But what wins the
fight is control. What wins the fight is
collaboration. Uh sorry, calibration,
strategic flexibility.
the fact that the new kid has many
different options and he's picking the
option that is most strategically
advantaged to him.
Okay. Now, and what you will notice from
this example is the bully doesn't have
that many options actually because he
needs to maintain the idea of face or
credibility. Right?
This is the essence of his power. The
his power lies in the fact that if you
do not listen to him, if you not obey
him, he will come and beat the crap out
of you, right? That's credibility.
And but the moment that you show that is
that actually it's actually not that big
of a deal to be punched by him. He's not
that strong. Then he loses all
credibility. Okay, which means that he
either retreats or he's forced to strike
harder to kill you. Okay, to maintain
his credibility. So, another way of
saying this is that
um by calibrating your movements
strategically, you can manipulate the
bully into selfdestruction.
Does it make sense, you guys?
All right,
any questions? Okay, so that's a theory.
All right, so now what we're going to do
is we're going to apply this theory, the
law of escalation to what's happening in
the Middle East. Okay, we're going to do
that by looking at the escalation
ladders of both Iran and the United
States. All right.
Okay,
this is the US. This is Iran.
Okay, so let's look at the escalation
ladder. So the first thing that United
States does of course is something
called decapitation.
What is decapitation? Decapitation is
like I just kill your leaders. You don't
have any more leaders and therefore you
don't know what to do and therefore you
surrender. Okay, that's the first thing
the US did. It didn't work. So now the
United States is doing is attacking
military targets, air defense
and military bases. Okay,
that's the second second step.
And the idea is that you beat the crap
out of the military so they surrender.
But that didn't work either. Okay. So
then what you do next of course is
economic embargo
where you basically prevent
Iran from trading with the world right
prevent Iran from selling oil to China
basically by blockading the seas and the
idea here is that if the government
doesn't have any money pay it soldiers
it soldiers will just not fight okay but
that didn't but that's not either. So
then what you do of course is you attack
civilian
infrastructure,
okay, which is primarily water and oil.
So you may have seen the news that the
Israelis attacked an oily pot in Tran.
And now you look if you look at pictures
of Tran, it's all black. Okay? And this
is a war crime or this goes against
international law because you're
attacking civilians. That's but that's
what you do when you feel as though you
need to apply more pressure to win this
war. Okay? And so you can keep on
escalating.
Um and then what you do is that now the
now that you've attacked the civilians
and they still refuse to surrender, what
you do now is you use secret weapons.
Secret weapons might be advanced
missiles that no one's ever seen before.
Okay? And the and the point of these
secret weapons is to scare the crap out
of people and say, "You see how dominant
we are?" Okay? If that doesn't work,
then what you do next is use biological
and chemical weapons. Okay? Biochemical
weapons
doesn't work either. then guys nuclear
weapons.
All right. So what's really important
for us to understand is that you must
follow this escalation ladder if you are
to use nuclear weapons. And the reality
is that first of all we have not seen
weapons. We have not seen biochemical
weapons and therefore nuclear weapons
comes later. Okay? Unless I see
biochemical weapons being used, I refuse
to believe that nuclear weapons is on
the table. Okay. All right. So, I think
we are here, which is the beginning of
attacks on civilian infrastructure, but
already we're seeing
um arguments in the American political
system against the use of um weapons
against civilians. Okay? And the reason
why is that if you do this, okay, if you
destroy civil infrastructure,
you unite the people behind the
government because the idea is that you
use air strikes to split apart the
government and the people and you want
the people to overthrow the government
for you. Okay, that's that's the idea
here. Um, so we are at this stage,
meaning that we have a long way to go
before we hit nuclear weapons. Okay. All
right. So now let's look at the uh
Iranian um escalation ladder. So what's
happening is that in the beginning Iran
does um
um two major things. Okay. The first is
attack
uh military targets. Okay.
And what they're basically targeting are
US radar systems and air defenses
because once these two things go then
Iran can attack whatever it wants. Okay.
It's also closed to moose.
All right. And by closing the st you put
pressure on the economies of the GCC as
well as East Asia. The hope is that um
by blockading the economies the GCC uh
UAE, Saudi Arabia, Bahan, Qatar, Kuwait
will put pressure on Donald Trump to end
this war as quickly as possible. Also
um East Asia receives most of its oil
from the GCC from the Shumus, right? So
China gets about 40% of its oil. Japan
gets 75%. Um that's a lot of oil. So the
hope is that these countries will put
pressure on the United States to end
this war as soon as possible. Okay? So
that is the uh Iranian strategy. But if
they're forced to go up the escalation
ladder, what will happen is this. If you
attack their economy, they will attack
your economy as well. Okay? With
missiles, basically targeting oil
fields.
If you attack their civil
infrastructure, they will attack your
civil infra infrastructure as well. And
what is the main weakness in these GCC
countries? Desalination plants. Okay,
desalination plants.
And that's it. Okay, that's the extent
of the Iranian
escalation ladder because it doesn't
have nuclear weapons. It doesn't have
biochemical weapons. Okay? It doesn't
have intercontinental
missiles that it can target the United
States with. So as you can see, oh the
US and Israel have escalation dominance
because it can go up way up higher in
escalation escalation ladder than Iran.
But that's the wrong way to understand
this. Okay? Because if you look at their
strategies, Iran has much more
flexibility, much more calibration
than the United States. Okay? When the
United States attacks you, it's pretty
blunt. But look, if I close all the
short moves, I can be strategic in how I
close the show moves. For example, if
you're a Chinese ship, I let you pass.
For example, if you are a GCC nation and
you want to bribe me, you want you want
to pay me a tax, I let you pass as well.
If you're a GC TCC nation, you're like,
you know what, forget the United States.
I want to be a friend Iran, I let you
pass as well. You understand? So by
closing all the swivel moves, it creates
a calibration strategy. It allows Iran
to selectively and strategically apply
pressure to the friends of the United
States so that they become the friends
of Iran. Okay. Same thing with these
drone strikes um against oil fields and
military targets, right?
If you attack me, I attack you with
drones. But if you don't attack me, then
I don't attack you. Okay? So in other
words, okay, this is really important
idea.
The US
and Iran
have different military
decision trees.
Okay? All right. So let me explain how.
Because United States and Israel,
they're just attacking Iran.
Okay. And they attack with air power. So
that's very blunt, right? Okay. So you
go from one step to the next to the next
to the next. Okay. This is this the
classic escalation ladder. Iran is not
like this. Their decision tree is
different. Okay? Because their strategy
is to force United States to omit defeat
and retreat from the GCC. Okay. To close
down the military bases in the Middle
East so that Iran has control over the
surgical moves and therefore it can
control all world trade.
All right. So that's a strategy. So this
strategy means that you have different
options. All right. Your options are um
attack Israel
um your mil military targets civil
targets Tel Aviv. Okay. All right. So I
don't want to spend too much time on
this but as you can see um if you think
about it Iran can be much more selective
in its targeting than United States and
Israel
and therefore the options that it has it
is much more diverse
which gives Iran escalation control
over the situation. Okay. Do you guys do
you guys do you guys understand this?
All right. So, let's
look at why Iran has uh advantages over
the gas station. Okay. US
Iran.
The first major difference is that Iran
is active
whereas the US is passive. Okay. Another
thing this is go back to the bully
example where the bully has to maintain
credibility. He has to show that he's
more powerful than the other than the
other kids, right? So if you provoke
him, he has no choice in the matter but
to hit you. Okay? But you the new kid
can choose whether or not to provoke him
or not. You can choose the timing of
when to provoke him. Therefore, you are
active. Okay. The second big difference
is that Iran has a clear strategy.
It knows what it wants to accomplish and
uh it knows how to accomplish what it
wants. Remember what what Iran wants is
control the moose and the United States
out of the Middle East. That's what it
wants to do. And it's calibrating its
attacks in a certain way to achieve this
end goal and it's working out very well
for Iran. Okay. The United States on the
other hand doesn't know what it wants.
It wants to destroy Iran. What does that
mean? Okay, destroy.
It could mean regime change. It could
mean economy collapses. It could mean um
the civilian population stars. Okay, it
could mean anything. But because there's
so much ambiguity, so much confusion
about what it means, it confuses
military strategy.
Right? And the last thing is of course
is that Iran is flexible
and United States is inflexible.
Okay. So by studying the escalation
ladder we discover that Iran has far
more advantages than the United States.
Okay. All right. So what so what does
this mean? All right. It means that Iran
will probably win this war ultimately.
But
um it has there has to be major changes
to society in order to win this war.
Right? So remember to win a fight you
have to have three things. Focus
um clarity and resolve.
All right.
You have to know what your purpose is.
You have to know how to achieve it and
you have to have you have to be
determined to achieve it. Okay. So, what
does this mean for the Middle East? What
does it mean for Iran? What first thing
is focus means unity?
Meaning that you have to unite your
population which means basically
crushing all descent. You can't we can't
argue anymore. We have to unify for a
purpose. Okay. The second thing clarity
is to uh censor people. Censorship.
And we're already seeing that in Israel
where you're not allowed to film
military strikes. Okay? If a drone comes
and attacks Tel Aviv in Israel, you
cannot film that and put on on social
media. Okay? The government will come
and arrest you. Same thing in Dubai. you
cannot show uh Dubai being attacked.
Okay, so massive censorship going on and
resolve just means militarization
where the Middle East moves towards
total war. Total war just means that
every citizen now is recruited into the
war effort. It just means that the
entire economy is geared towards
um war. Okay. And um one last point I'll
make is this. What we need to understand
about the escalation ladder is that as
it moves up, we have to remember that
this war is being fought
multi-dimensionally.
Okay, what does that mean? It means that
the military is just one dimension, but
there are four major dimensions. There
are others, but let's focus on four
major dimensions. Okay, the first major
dimension is narrative.
Narrative is basically world opinion.
Second
um is political. Political just means
the relationship of nations to each
other. The relationship of the n of the
government to the people. Okay.
Political. The third dimension is
economical economic
and the fourth is military.
And what's really important to
understand is that the military
dimension is probably the least
important. There are other dimensions
that are much more important.
Therefore, these four factors determine
how the United States and Iran move up
the escalation ladder. Okay? Because
your purpose is to control the narrative
and justify why you're doing what you're
doing. Uh political means you you still
have to maintain good relations with
other states, right? So as United States
is fighting this war against Iran,
United States is is still talking to
China. United States is still talking to
Russia. Okay. So that discussion that
political discussion determines the
contours of this fight. Economic means
that as the fight is still happening,
nations are still trading with each
other and that factors into how the
military is fought. Okay, does that make
sense? So I know this is very
complicated but you need you need to
understand how complicated war is. It's
not as simple as saying you know what
let's nuke that guy. Doesn't work that
way. Okay. There are a lot of
constraints. There's a lot of factors a
lot of stakeholders involved to
constrain the use of nukes. Okay. All
right. All right. So let's now discuss
ground troops. All right. Right. The
first question we look at is will ground
troops be used and the answer
unfortunately is yes. They have to be
used and it has to do with how the
military works okay of how wars are
fought. Basically when you fight a war
you have to have a correct cost pyramid.
Okay.
And the most simple cost pyramid, okay,
is is this
infantry soldiers, okay?
All right. They're at the bottom. Why?
Because they're the cheapest.
What's above them? Armor.
Okay. Artillery, tanks.
They're more expensive to produce. You
need more resources. You need more time.
Then you have naval, right? Then you
have ear.
Okay, it doesn't make sense. This is the
cost pyramid. And cost pyramid just is
this question of like how much energy,
how much time, how much resources do you
need, do do you need to produce a
certain product. Okay, it cost you very
little to prod produce a soldier, but it
cost you a lot to produce an airplane.
This is important because wars are
usually wars of attrition meaning that
you have to put all your resources into
winning the war. Okay. So this is just
um production capacity
and this is the most standard model that
you have of a cost pyramid for a
military war. Okay, does it make sense
guys? The problem is that the United
States have an inverse pyramid. Okay.
Meaning that ear is what's dominant,
then naval,
then
uh armor, then soldiers.
You can't fight a war like this. I mean,
the moment you choose to fight a war
like this, you've lost the war because
you either take out the country in like
two days or you screwed over because you
cannot replenish your forces. Now I I I
know this is hard to understand but 1991
the Persian Gulf War, 2003 the Iraq war,
these are not real wars, okay? Because
the Americans were so dominant and Iraq
was so weak that it was basically a
video game. All right, this is these
these pilots flying around is bombing
everything. Okay, it's like guys and
tanks just running over the ar the Iraqi
army. Those were just video games. But
this Iran thing is a real war and
therefore you cannot fight a war like
this. If you want to win this war, the
only thing you can do is return
to a realistic cost pyramid. You don't
have a choice in the matter, right?
Because again, your cheapest
um product are soldiers,
right? And your most expensive are
airplanes. You cannot afford to use an
airplane in order to site to save a life
of a soldier. Eventually, this
costbenefit analysis will blow up on
you. Okay?
Okay. Does that make sense, guys? All
right. So, United States wants to win
this war, then it has no choice but to
use ground troops to use soldiers as the
main force of its military. Any
questions so far? All right. Okay. Now
the question then is
will the United States use ground
troops? I already said that if United
States is to win this war, it has no
choice but to use ground troops. But
will the United States use ground
troops? And a lot is determined by the
game theory strategies of the different
players. Okay. So let's look at
the four major players in this war.
You have US, you have Israel,
you have Saudi Arabia,
and you have Iran.
Okay. All right. So, United States and
Iran, they're pretty easy to understand.
What the United States wants to do is
destroy Iran.
Okay? Why? Because if you destroy Iran,
United States would have complete
control over Middle East oil
and it would control global trade for
the straight of humus and therefore the
United States can maintain its empire.
Okay, so a really simple objective,
let's destroy Iran. We don't care how,
we don't care why, let's just go do it.
Okay, Iran has another strategy which is
control
straight moose
and
destroy
sencom. Sencom is basically uh the
American military in the Middle East
called central command. Okay. So those
those are two major military objectives
of Iran and we can understand why
because if sitcom is destroyed Iran has
complete control over the Middle East.
Now
Dubai, now uh Oman, Ban, Kuwait have to
pay taxes to Iran. Now Iran, the new kid
is now the bully of the Middle East.
Right now it's a hgeimon. That is the
political objective of this war. Okay.
Um Israel is a bit more complicated.
All right. For Israel, oh sorry, sorry,
sorry. One other thing is humble Israel.
That that's the other thing because even
even if you defeat the United States,
you still have to deal with Israel,
okay? And Israel is the great military
power of the Middle East. So you want to
humble them. You want to weaken them.
You can't destroy Israel because Israel
has nuclear weapons, right? You piss off
Israel, those nukes start flying. You
don't want that, right? So those are the
three major political objectives for
Iran. Control the moves, destroy SNCOM,
and humble Israel. Okay? If you are
Israel
actually for you
the strategy is different. What you want
to do is this. You want to destroy
Sencom
and destroy Iran.
Okay, those are objectives. Why? Because
if you destroy both United States and
you destroy Iran,
then you are the sole hegeimon in the
Middle East. Okay? also destroy the GCC,
destroy Saudi Arabia as well. Why?
Because once Saudi Arabia is destroyed,
all its resources belong to you. Okay?
And then this creates something called
the Greater Israel Project, which is
what we will discuss next class. But as
you can see, that's really important is
that even though United States and
Israel are allies,
their automo strategy is different.
Their objectives are different. In fact,
they're in conflict. Okay. They have
Saudi Arabia. What does Saudi Arab
Arabia want to do? Well, destroy Iran
because if you destroy Iran, you have
complete control of the moves. Then you
you can be a bully. Okay? But you also
want to destroy
the US and you want to humble Israel.
All right? Does that make sense? All
right. So by understanding how each
player perceives the game, we can now
understand how they will go about their
strategy. Right? So the United States
just wants to destroy Iran. But as you
can see, Israel, Saudi Arabia, and Iran
all want to destroy the United States.
And how do you do that? You do that by
forcing the United States into a long
ground war.
Right?
Therefore, if you're Israel, you don't
want to use nukes. Why? Because nukes
would end the war too quickly. You want
to drag this war out as long as possible
to force the United States to send in
ground troops.
And you're like, well, why doesn't the
United States use nuclear weapons? And
the answer I is already told you the
escalation ladder. It needs to justify
justify itself to the to the people.
Okay? When you do anything, all right,
when you do anything,
sorry, when you do anything, you have to
worry about certain factors. Okay? You
have to worry about troop morale.
Your soldiers have to believe that they
are fighting for a good cause. Okay? You
have to worry about public opinion.
You have to make sure that the world is
on your side. You have to worry about
politics, political will. You have to
make sure the people are unified. Uh,
and you have to worry about enemy
morale.
You don't want to piss off the person,
your enemy so much that they go into an
extreme, uh, they jump the escalation
ladder to too to extreme beyond beyond
your control. Okay, does that make
sense? Okay. So, as you can see, war is
extremely complicated. It's not just
about weaponry. It's not just about um
resources. It's ultimately about
controlling the narrative, controlling
the political landscape. Okay?
Marshalling the resources in a proper
way that is strategically beneficial.
All right?
Does that make sense to you guys? Okay.
So, um yeah. So, we we just answered two
questions. Will the NC use ground
troops? Yes, it will because Iran, Saudi
Arabia, and Israel will work together to
force a ground invasion even though the
United States doesn't want to do so. But
unfortunately, United States doesn't
have a clear coherent strategy. It's
passive. Therefore, it can be
manipulated into sending a ground
invasion. Okay. And the second question
is, will Israel, United States use
nuclear weapons? And the answer is no
because it's not in their best interest
to use nuclear weapons. Okay? Israel
wants the United States to lose this
war. And that means a long war that
destroys the American political will to
fight any more foreign wars. If America
loses, Israel becomes the dominant power
in the Middle East. Okay.
And so the last question is the Alaxic
Mosque and we will answer that
next class on Thursday. Any questions?
Will will Americans take over Iran like
what they did to Venezora
like they captured their president?
Okay, look. The strategy in the
beginning was to do a Venezuela in Iran,
meaning you go in, you kill the leader,
a new leader emerges, negotiate with
you, and and surrender to you because
you're too powerful. Okay? But Venezuela
and Iran are two very different
countries. The Venezuelan elite is very
pro-American, meaning that their their
wealth, their children, their family is
stored in America. Therefore, the
Venezuelan elite have invested interest
in negotiating a deal with America to
protect their own interests. But for uh
40 plus years, America has sanctioned
the Iranian elite and Iran has become
poor and angry and disgruntled because
of that. Therefore, they have they lose
nothing by fighting you. Okay? So, even
though you've killed the supreme leader
and you've killed many of their leaders,
in fact, the elite themselves are
unified in opposing you. Okay. Does that
make sense? Okay. Any more questions? Uh
yep.
Um Allan
>> so I in fact have a question about the
motivation of US to involve in this war.
like uh as you said that US want to
control all the all the oil so like they
must destroy Iran but I I think this is
like a little bit confusing because uh I
think US know that this war is really uh
highly risk and it can potentially even
like destroy the whole systems. So why
US risk the the the risk of like whole
system collapsing to like control the
oil that Iran had? Okay. All right. So,
this is the um key question that
everyone's arguing about. Quite
honestly, we're going to argue this for
the rest of eternity. Okay. We're we're
going to argue this for eternity because
like no one knows and there's never
going to be a clear answer. In fact,
there are multiple possibilities. Okay?
What what I'm going to do today is offer
you the most simple explanation. In the
next class, I will offer you a much more
complicated explanation. Okay? But
simple explanation is this. Again, this
goes back to military doctrine. Um, how
the United States military works. Okay?
And the military doctrine is prevent the
heartland from arising. Right? So,
United States is here.
This is Europe.
This is Russia.
This is Iran.
India,
China,
Japan,
this is um Middle East
and this is Africa. All right. So the
American military doctrine is this.
The greatest threat to American power is
the heartland unifying.
Okay? Why? Because if the heartland
unifies, it can trade by itself through
railways.
But America is primary a naval power.
Therefore, it requires people to trade
by sea.
Okay? And so its strategy is to make
sure there's never any cohesion
in the heartland
either by making sure that no great
power arises in the heartland. And
that's why America went went to war in
World War I and World War II because
there's a great fear that Germany would
conquer the world or Europe and Asia and
create the heartland. Okay? Therefore,
America has to stop Germany from rising.
Um so you either make sure no great
power arises or you create so much
conflict that they're always fighting
each other. And that used to work
before. Okay. Now there's a problem. The
problem is the bricks nations Russia,
Iran and China are coming together and
if they come together guys that's a
major piece of the heartland and
everyone else Europe Middle East Africa
with India was probably follow because
this is easier to trade in the heartland
it is trade with America especially with
the US dollar declining
right so in other words United States
has no no choice but to fight this war
because That's their entire strategy to
maintain hegemony in the world to
prevent the heartland from unifying.
All right? Does that make sense? Because
like once you destroy Iran,
the heartland fractures.
There's no way that they can now trade
together anymore. They're still reliant
on American
um maritime routes. Okay. America
maintains the head is still the
hedgeimon because it controls world
trade. Whoever controls world trade
controls the world. Whoever controls the
heartland controls world trade. Okay.
Does that make sense? Okay. But this is
just one explanation. There's actually
other explanations and I I'll go into a
more complicated explanation next class.
All right. Any more questions? Yep.
So you mentioned Saudi Arabia and how it
wants to see the downfall of both uh the
US and Iran.
>> He wants to see the downfall of Israel,
>> Yeah. And to me that sounds like a
pretty big goal. And how would you say
how would they possibly use their
strategy to achieve that goal or how
would it possibly be for Saudi Arabia?
>> Okay. All right. So, it's very confusing
to people why Saudi Arabia is actually
against Iran. Okay. But actually, if you
go back and look at their history, they
have major conflicts with each other.
All right. So, let's go over uh some
some of their conflicts.
All right. So, uh Saudi Arabia, Iran,
the first major conflict is that Iran is
a theocracy
and Saudi Arabia is a monarchy.
A theocracy just means that you're ruled
by clerics who represent God. A monarchy
is a king who represents God. And for
the Iranians, that is blasphemy. That's
heresy. That's against the religion.
Okay? So Saudi Arabia and Iran hate each
other. Saudi Arabia sees Iran as a
threat and trying to induce a revolution
within Saudi Arabia. Iran sees Saudi
Arabia as blasphemous. Okay.
And it's a huge issue because Saudi
Arabia is the home of Mecca Medina, the
two holiest sites in the Islamic world.
Okay. Second issue is that uh Saudi
Arabia is Sunni and Shia uh and Iran is
Shia. So these are two different sects
of the same religion, but it's like
Protestants and Catholics. They just
hate each other. Okay. Um Okay. And the
last thing is that Iran uh is anti-US
and Shiat and Saudi Arabia is pro- US.
What this means is that Saudi Arabia has
military bases, American military bases
inside of the Holy Land. And for the
Iranians, that is the worst crime,
right? Because it's infidels who are
protecting the Holy Land. Infidels are
not allowed in the Holy Land, right?
You're not if if you're not a Muslim,
you're not allowed to go to Mecca. All
right.
All right. So, Saudi Arabia and Iran
hate each other. Saudi Arabia has a huge
problem in that it is an oil economy.
It's most of its GDP comes from or
exports. And for the longest time, it
was trying to build a notch economy. It
was trying to build tourism. It was
trying to promote games. Okay. does not
work. So if you're Saudi Arabia and you
see the future, it's a pretty dismal
future because eventually your oil is
going to run out. Eventually people are
going to switch to electrical vehicles
digitization which means that oil is no
longer so imported. Okay. So what you
need to do is if you're able to control
the Middle East, right? So where where
you get your money now is from trade
access.
That's a viable future. If you just sit
back and wait, eventually
your nation is going to run out of oil
and therefore it's going to cease to
exist. Okay? So, Saudi Arabia needs to
act now and it needs and the way that it
wants to act is it wants to create a
conflict between United States, Israel
and Iran where they destroy each other.
Once they destroy each other, Saudi
River can come up on top. Now, Israel
cannot be destroyed because Israel has
nuclear weapons. But the goal is to
negotiate a peace with Israel after the
war is over. Right? Does it make sense?
To split the Middle East between Israel
and Saudi Arabia.
But will Israel agree to this deal?
Probably not. But according to game
theory, Saudi Arabia has no choice in
this matter because it is so far behind
everyone else. Okay? You can only hope
that this chaos leads to new
possibilities because given the
structure of the game so far, it does
not have a very good future. Okay, does
that make sense? All right, any more
questions, guys?
All right. Okay, great questions. So,
please continue to follow the war. Okay,
so you have to follow the war and
understand what's going on. And in this
class, what I'm doing is I'm providing
you the game theory analysis for you to
understand what's happening and why it's
happening and where this war is going.
Okay? Again, the three big predictions I
make
um and we'll know in the next year or
two if these things three things happen
or not is the United States will send in
ground troops. It has no choice in the
matter if it wants to win this war or
continue this war. There will be no
nuclear weapons being used. Again, I
will apologize to the world if new
glorins are are used. Okay. The third is
that the Alexic mosque will be destroyed
at some point and it's something I will
talk about next